open up your wallet america president
biden wants trillions more of your tax
dollars
four hours from now biden will be giving
his first address before a joint session
of congress
the president's american family's plan
coming with a whopper of a price tag
at nearly two trillion dollars including
items like
free universal preschool two years free
community college
12 weeks of paid family leave and child
care assistance and biden plans to play
for it
by raising the top capital gains tax to
nearly 40 percent
and giving 80 billion dollars to the irs
to boost audits on high earners
republican lawmakers ripping into the
spending spree
president biden is is governing like a
drunken sailor when you talk about this
spending
i mean i got trillions and trillions of
dollars and one bill was over 2 trillion
this bill is going to be over 2 trillion
who do you think's going to pay for this
the underlying policies that are being
implemented this is not
a moderate agenda this is not a unity
agenda this
is a radical agenda his strategy i think
so far
and will continue to be just wants to
ram this down the american people's
throat all right brian kilmeade will be
watching
tonight taking notes and trying to get
to bed early so he can come out and say
what he has to say in the morning brian
this looks like the
biggest expansion of the federal
government since
lyndon johnson's great society which
kind of was a
had a mixed track record what do you see
coming down the pipeline tonight well i
mean if you look at
fdr he had to respond to a depression
and a war
and he got this huge mandate he gets his
big elections got the party in power in
every way house and senate got it then
you look at what you just mentioned
about the great society we were a nation
fractured we have
black and white bathrooms back of the
bus rosa parks we remember all that
that was a nation screaming for civil
rights
justice this is a nation that is about
to come
screaming out of a pandemic when the
when the tractor was forced to pull to
the side of the road for almost a year
now we're ready to get on that road and
it's clear we don't need
this we don't need a restructuring we
are getting it jammed down our throats
49 of the country does not pay taxes so
the 51 percent that do
are the bad guys and ladies and now
you're gonna have to work twice as hard
for less can you imagine six out of
every ten dollars
that you make is going to the government
for six months you are working for free
congratulations that's called the that's
called the recipe
for non-production and he acts like he's
a hero using other people's money
this irs thing is the biggest story to
emerge out of this there's nothing worse
than an empowered irs
destroying finances in order to crack
down and find
some way to get more billions of dollars
for social programs
we don't need yeah i got audited a few
years ago
and i'm thinking to myself i was so nice
to donald trump why is his irs
coming after me like that it cost me a
fortune
and i didn't even do anything wrong dana
perrino you brought this
the other day um i think what the the
trump administration spent about
6 trillion last year and biden's on pace
already for another 6 trillion that's
12 trillion if my math is correct in the
course of one year
does it even matter anymore it's
interesting
because the markets don't seem to think
so and i'm paying attention to that and
to brian's point about the irs
independent think tanks have shown
that the number that biden's team says
that they'll be able to recoup
from fraud and waste and abuse and going
after people
is a fraction of what they're saying
they're going to be able to get
the other thing that was eye-opening to
me was that in the nbc poll you know
everybody did a poll this past weekend
about
biden's job approval in the nbc paul
jesse
there was a number that really stood out
biden is four points
underwater on taxes and spending so only
45 percent of people
approve of him on taxes and spending 49
percent disapprove
and his answer to that and his plan
tonight is to double down on more taxes
and spending um but when you don't have
the markets reacting i think that that
is something this
is to look into there's two other things
that happen today that again get swept
under the rug
he took a pass on trying to expand
medicare which is something bernie
sanders really wanted
and the second thing is they're not
going to go after the pharmaceutical
companies like they promised in the
campaign
those two things getting swept under the
rug the unity
issue it's dead i think that was dead
after the first six hours when he killed
the keystone pipeline
but the unity message that he's been
able to secure
is amongst the democrats with the
progressive left
and i think a lot of the wall street
titans are probably thinking they can
hire a bunch of lobbyists and beat back
a lot of the capital gains hike talks
all right juan williams this is this is
your typical tax and spend
grow the government make people more
dependent
create more programs and tax the wealthy
this is no different
than anything any other liberals trying
to do since 1930.
am i wrong about that
i think you're wrong i think you're
speaking like a wealthy man jesse i mean
the reality is
and i think this is what you hear from
president biden tonight
he's saying the president is saying to
the working-class
people in this country saying to the
middle class in this country it's your
turn
you know what we have always taken care
of wall street and the fat
cats in this country after the recession
in 09
people said how come you know those
people on wall street walked away with
you know hands full of money well this
time i think biden is saying we're
looking at
he was the vice president when people
who go to work every day
in america so so my sense is that you
know you look at the earned income
tax credit it's going to be increased
you look at child
care and you look at universal pre-k
this helps women
who have children get back to work
they're going to help with health care
costs
they're going to help with community
college so people can get the skills
they need to work
so this is all about helping people who
are working people in this country
and you know i just want to reiterate
dana perrino's point
this isn't any socialist far left agenda
there was nothing no medicare for all
here
no canceling of student debt no
universal basic
income no guaranteed jobs so it's
none of that in terms of the the the
socialist agenda that you guys want to
make this after it's not real
wait
for everybody that works to take care of
kids
but it's not guaranteed jobs for all
americans which was the proposal but i
just want to reiterate something to go
back to something that you were talking
about which was taxes
because unlike unlike the trump tax cut
everything that biden has proposed is
paid for
and fox polls show most americans
support having the rich and the big
companies
all right pay with higher taxes it's
paid for because
it doesn't mean anything agenda
that doesn't mean a thing all right
katie
well first of all 81 of americans
including the middle class got a tax cut
under president trump i know that people
wanted to lie about that and say
they only gave tax cuts to the rich but
actually the vast majority of the
country
got a tax cut the road to hell is paid
with good intentions and it's the same
thing for the road to socialism when you
add up all these different bills
whether it's the green new deal
repackaged as infrastructure
or this new human infrastructure bill it
all goes back to the leftist idea of
expanding
the state expanding the federal
government expanding
a people's reliability on the federal
government which is very difficult then
to take back so while they're offering
women free health care for example
well for or free child care for example
they may not
go back to their job because their
corporation or their small business cut
their job so
great they have quote free health care
or free child
care for their family but they don't
have an actual job to pay for the other
things and they don't have choices when
it comes
to what they want to spend their own
money on when it comes
to child care and what are we getting
for this i mean democrats have been
arguing
for decades now almost 100 years that
the war on poverty is something that we
need to win well if you look at the
poverty rate
when we started the war on poverty you
know long long time ago 1940s
what have we gotten for it the rate is
still essentially the same and so
this is about joe biden breaking another
campaign promise
unity was one of them as dana said but
the next one is
he said specifically i'm not a socialist
i beat the socialist in october trying
to get moderate
voters to vote for him and get him over
the finish line when you have
half of the squad saying they are very
impressed with joe biden's leftist
progressive agenda
he's on the road to socialism and it's
not a good one for the american people
to be on